it's so funny too because when i was
doing the transcripts like one of the
things that happens is
the the the doctor says to the judge
your honor
mr amadeo realizes he could face
up to five years and the prosecutor goes
25 years your honor and he goes 25 years
so the doctor's like 25 he's like we
know it could be significant
anyway i mean that you read the
transcripts it's hilarious
wow your else is hilarious listen
actually goes to a board meeting one
time wearing a darth vader mask
a [ __ ] yeah aboard me goes the board
puts the document goes in sits down and
conducts an hour-long board meeting in
the mass
and he's so he's so um
you know manic and just off the rails
and you just don't know what he's going
to do like nobody says anything
now it's a perfect character for him
darth vader yeah
it is that's what you think that's what
he wants to be actually i interviewed
one of the uh does he have any kids
see where it sounds like the stories
that make sense now where does kids live
uh ones one lives in australia and the
other ones in orlando
so anyway so one of the people that i
i interviewed one of the guys one of the
ceos
i think he was a ceo that i interviewed
of his company he
he says amadeo was like a little darth
vader being followed around by
stormtroopers and i really
love that image he said that would have
been the cover of the book that should
have been the cover of the book for sure
so then like i remember hearing about
the meeting right
then when i was reading the transcripts
this chick edie
uh her name is uh [ __ ] i don't know
anyway edie
she ends up saying in there she talks
about how yeah oh listen one time he
came into a meeting wearing a [ __ ]
helmet
uh darth vader helmet conducted the
entire meeting i wouldn't so i
heard it was just dying laughing i was
like oh [ __ ]
god i mean i can't get into the whole
book
but bro it's so over the top insane i
think i spit on your mic
i'm sorry um it's so over the top just
insane germ it up
actually gonna do
irresponsible over the top insane that i
mean you can't get into the whole thing
like you read it and you go
this why is this not a movie look so
when i went to la i met with two
producers
about the book like they were you in l.a
last week last week
they're like this is this is nuts oh
yeah we talked about for like an hour
they're like this
this is this is ins this is insanity and
the thing is you can look it up and
you'll see
you'll see little bits and pieces of it
when you put it all together and realize
what was really happening
it's it's just i want them to make a
movie about
its insanity and i want jonah hill to
play amadeo don't wait jonah hill camp
what yeah jonah hill's perfect for
amadeus
jonah hill joan hill's amazing you might
need like joe pesci no like no
he's true he was probably in his late
30s early 40s when most of this is
happening
in his 40s how old is no danny was too
old did he play the penguin
he did yeah
anyway wolf of wall street with like
those teeth and everything oh yeah
that's definitely
big when he plays devaroli yeah he does
so i got the after action report from
the congo i've got the medical reports
i've got all the transcripts i got bro
buy it now i got the anyway the book's
on amazon crazy
the books on amazon amazon.com it's a
great
book it's amazing everybody buy the book
and it's only 160 it's only 100
160 pages matt cox 69 gmail.com send
some money
mattcock69 i love it
so was the last time you actually talked
to amadeo
oh uh the day before i left prison
really like i can't
talk to him because he's i mean i can't
allow to talk to you yeah i'm not
allowed to talk to him i i could
cut i mean because he's a fellow i could
if i told my probation officer look i
wrote a book about this guy i'd like to
talk to him
but you know i haven't and he you know
you think he'd talk to you
yeah i think he would i think he can i
know he talks what do you think he's
doing now
i don't know i i think i mean i know he
was running
i know he he was planning on starting
some type of uh
a company or something to do um
post-conviction work for
prisoners but i don't know how well that
went i haven't really reached out to him
i haven't
he hasn't reached out to me we basically
there's a guy named donovan davis
donovan davis's wife like i've talked to
his wife several times and
and amadeo talks to the wife so she's
like he's doing good he's doing that
and you know that but that's it like we
don't pass messages we didn't really
talk because like i could call him
um you know i could ask her hey what's
his phone number what's his
but i would have to ask my p.o and i'm
gonna do that i'm gonna call him i don't
really
need to do that yeah there's no reason
to do it he's got to be something though
i can't just picture him
so he's home doing nothing well listen
he's he's he's got it
he got 22 here's the thing he got 22
years right so when i leave when i left
he still had 10 years to go
and then when six months six months
later to a year so how does he how
the [ __ ] is he out right now he got his
no he got it through like the second
chance act or something
he convinced the court to to
um basically allow him to serve the
remainder of his sentence at home
under house arrest because they said he
said that they don't have the facilities
to treat his mental illness
so he has to be at home so they said
yeah you're right we don't we can't
really give you the right
um you know counseling and
and drugs and monitoring so we're gonna
let you go home and so you can go to an
actual hospital and
and do that and that's so he got
transferred to uh home confinement
which is 10 years of home confinement
i've never heard of that in my life
but it never opens right now because it
never happens that is pretty insane
yeah it's nuts she's the only lawyer to
ever do that
oh i'm the only inmate i've ever heard
that's done that
and he happened to be both his inmate he
was his own lawyer right
oh yeah he i think he yeah uh well he is
now
now he's you know once you're locked up
they don't give you a lawyer you're done
now you just file
and [ __ ] yourself
[Music]
you're pro se paypal ain't working bro
what is the deal somebody sent me people
are complaining that they can't send you
money
well that's up that is upset i just
that's upsetting i just sent
you i just sent it to you what do you
send to me
my paypal so send it to him i don't have
my phone with me
what's your i mean what is the deal i've
got a paypal you leave your phone in the
car
no it's over there charging oh i mean
this is my paypal i showed you what if
you have to text somebody during the
podcast
just copy and paste you can't copy and
paste the link in there he didn't send
it to me
i'm trying to give me your phone or
write your phone number down tell it on
the chat okay look yeah okay
so that's you know seven two seven
sixteen four twenty
matt six eight eight four nine three
okay so
that's a throwback okay oh i was oh yeah
you're right that's your number
you know if i typed it yeah so what else
did you do when you're out in uh
california about the homeless population
in in
in california is it's kind of together
right now yeah because they changed the
laws now they can actually keep all
their luggage out in the streets
it's ridiculous look somebody told me i
don't know if this is true this is what
a guy told me
that they don't they'll arrest you like
if you steal and it's under 500
they'll arrest them they take them
downtown they process them they release
them
so the every place you go to downtown
has an armed guard
well i don't know they weren't armed if
you steal and it's under five hundred
dollars
they don't prosecute you they arrest you
take you downtown they they print you
and everything they book you and let you
right back out
so every place downtown has a uh
they all have uh guards they all have
security through a weed shop on
melrose and there's this like seven foot
dude with this giant [ __ ]
he had like a full-sized glock on his
hip
and it looks like just homeless people
everywhere one of those mini that's a
lot of socials out there
oh man i'm telling you i mean
it's uh that's a social galore it's a
buffet
that's a social buffet i mean this guy
figured it out
yeah he sent a dollar ninety nine no he
said somebody said twenty-five
twenty-five bucks sign a book for him
kyle roberts kyle roberts paid you 25
bucks
he's five bucks short of getting signed
a book came through he almost got
something kyle's all right
so sign a book for him i'm i mean i'm
going to him and he's going to go awol
if you don't know
right now on the podcast yeah sign it on
the
camera
that's daniel i'm saying what if he
wants something special what if he says
hey say this
just make it up say hey kyle kyle what
do you want him to say what do you want
me to say bro so yeah two [ __ ]
what did we call ha ha hold on
hang on but what what they use what we
used to call kyle
owl kyle alberts
hey wait a minute does kyle want it's
insanity or does he
wants its insanity of course that's what
this podcast is all about
it's insanity oh somebody just dropped
100 bucks
the doctor the doctor oh my god matt
your groupies are blowing it up
did they actually donate it or they sent
it to his paypal super chat super shot
hundo
goodbye sorry doctor thanks that
investment just gave him on her box
don't refund it please doc we appreciate
your support yeah
uh yeah he's no he's good keeping the
nightmare alive
i